what is the art of satisfaction that is
a question we have tried to master for
years how do you satisfy someone how do
you touch the pleasure zone of someone's
brain with a render you're not even
worth my time we already know who the
master is here oh yes yes tick-tock
famous
as you pan over to god
this way
we're on the hunt
for the pleasure receptors in people's
brains okay and it's our job to render
out some pixels that reach that target
all right is this a rated r video or are
we keeping this pg this is a satisfying
render challenge
here's a topic we've discussed
frequently the unsatisfying render a
render so unsatisfying it folds back on
itself and becomes satisfying again it's
a golf pipe that's going straight for
the hole and then bounces off of it
instead of going in it's more about the
betrayal of expectations than to leave
the viewer going oh what a waste of time
close out throw your phone whatever you
do i personally think that might be a
good spin on this interesting we have
done the classic satisfying render quite
a few times maybe it's time to switch it
up i think it is time to do the
unsatisfying render it's all about
making a satisfying render that just
doesn't deliver i like this it's got to
be satisfyingly unsatisfying so how do
you even do that good question we're
going to explore that today sam you
already did the unsatisfying render on
them yeah yeah you're right
the little globs the globs that we
missed
i unknowingly have already ventured into
this territory so i'm good so we're only
really gonna have a day maybe a day and
a half to really do these effects here
so we gotta make sure that we are not
being overly ambitious no promises i
know it's a struggle for other people to
do such a thing let's do it okay all
right we got this all right three two
one
so i think i've discovered that back
door to your pleasure receptors i don't
have a lot of time i don't want to do
something too
intricate and i started playing around
with physics once again physics is fun
because it's unexpected you know like
you can see a task you're trying to do
but physics itself will work against you
so i've set up an elaborate set for a
crane to carry a statue of myself up to
a pedestal but along the way there are
obstacles that are going to try and stop
me i'm just trying to carry this little
statue here
and uh
i'm actually trying to keep it steady
that's the thing
yeah and just like slightly bump it like
that
wait we're good
and then try and like flip it up
for me like just doing this has that
feeling that's like half tension half
satisfaction going on then i've gone in
and started populating it with more
advanced objects like it starts here and
it just like instantly knocks some cones
and stuff over i really like the idea of
like like it's swinging and like it tips
on to it and then we have to like flip
it back up
and
it doesn't work and then it just resets
but basically in order to get this done
from this point forward i've decided
that i'll be the statue that is trying
to be carried i need a photo scan of
myself so let's do that today we're
using the one and only polycam look i
love reality capture it's great for like
really intense huge scans but polycam is
way different first off it's on your
phone and second of all it does a lot of
the work for you so when you just need a
3d model it's definitely the fastest and
most effective way to do it yeah i had a
bit of a tough time coming up with
something that i felt was equal parts
satisfying and frustrating in the end
what i opted to do was build an obstacle
course where you get through 99 of it
and you just hit a roadblock at the very
end and are left wanting which i think
is the point of this whole thing the
emotional ups and downs of satisfaction
for me trying to find the line between
ambition and the time limit that we have
has been quite challenging to be totally
honest i think i bit off a little more
than i could chew so i've had to kind of
reduce the idea as i go my concept is
essentially we're following one ball's
majestic travels through this quirky
bubblegum environment it's essentially
just an obstacle course for a marble i
didn't really anticipate how long it was
going to take to build all this stuff
from scratch essentially i'm keeping my
shapes very simple i'm using booleans to
cut objects into other objects and just
shaping very simple geometry that took a
better part of half a day to build my
obstacle course and then i actually
needed to simulate the obstacle course
too because if it doesn't actually make
it to the end what's the point right
last night i was here kind of late at
least as far as i am normally here and i
was having an issue with one of the
simulations that i was working on for
two hours it starts on a slide and the
ball comes down the slide and shoots off
the end and that's the beginning of
everything i pushed play on the
simulation and the ball immediately fell
off the slide without doing anything at
all so essentially what you're about to
see in my final render is a hybrid of
traditional simulation and hand
animation hopefully you can't see where
the seams are because that means i lose
you know that's the fun of it right
that's why we're having fun here that's
why you got that ketchup packet right
there this yeah this is for emergency
only brake seal if hungry enough to eat
pure ketchup you know what that means
time for some shots no
do it is it time
kind of feels like time oh
this is devastating can't even get it
you're too weak
you're you're cracking open the
emergency ketchup right now i need it
dude i'm struggling whoa but i can't get
it open hard times can you have a poor
boy oh yeah i got you look this is my
first rodeo on the emergency ketchup all
right yeah there we go shake it on up
administer right under the tongue
that's all for you buddy
taking those uh oh that didn't help at
all i feel worse now
i don't know why you did that it's
really gross i thought it would help
[Music]
does he have a noodle for a sword i
totally just noticed he's got freaking
spaghetti sword hands uh i mean i'm
still in the process of making it i'm
kind of in the later stages of setting
up the scene but i've already kind of
like built out the blueprint and sort of
the underlying animation hold up i gotta
see if my freaking package arrived it
didn't arrive yesterday it was supposed
to
wait six stops away so did you ever play
with those little popper toys you put
like a little quarter into the little
thingy and you twist the other thingy
and then some balls would shake and
you'd open up the flap and you'd have a
little plastic thing you pry the cap off
and hurt your fingernails in the process
and out pops this little popper toy and
it's really cool it's made out of rubber
you press it in and invert it and it
turns into a little ticking time bomb
you put it upside down on the ground and
then
whoa oh that was satisfying
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
going into this project i thought this
is a satisfying sound effect so i kind
of thought you know what this might be a
bit of a shared experience i think we
all know what these toys are we can all
hear them already the general idea is
that it rolls in compresses it down
flips it over and then camera gets down
low as we see it just a little bit it's
starting to go starting to go in the
yeah this is a deficient popper toy
factory so this is about as far as i've
gotten right now i hopefully will have
something way better by tomorrow morning
when we got to show this off to everyone
a couple years ago cinema 4d came out
with what's called the volume modeling
system which is pretty sweet this is
where my style of modeling makes so much
more sense if i was to group all of
these into a volume builder here and
take all three of these things and put
it in it look at what happens it turns
to these weird things but now they're
all just this one volume of objects i
can make the sphere instead of union and
joining together i can make this a
subtract and suddenly that sphere is
tracking away from the cube but this is
still in a volume state you gotta mesh
it now so i will take this and i'll put
it into a volume mesher turns it back
into a 3d model and you'll notice it
actually adds like a little bit of
rounding around the corners where stuff
joins up but this is like a single mesh
you can actually see the polygons when i
zoom in anyway this is all a long story
to show you how i made this little
stupid thing here check this out i'm
going to delete all of these so the
anatomy of a pauper toy is basically
just a half dumb right but you know
things have thickness to them so how do
you make that thickness so i'm just
going to go ahead and start by making a
sphere i'm going gonna give it a lot of
subdivisions maybe a hundred
and then i'm going to make a cube but
i'm gonna lower that down to maybe just
above the halfway point i'm gonna put
both of those inside our volume builder
here but we need the cube to subtract
from the sphere so i'm actually going to
set the cube to be subtract and boom
just like that we have a bit of a half
dome but you see it's not
it's just it's capped we gotta fix that
so i'm gonna actually duplicate our
sphere i'm gonna make it a little bit
smaller maybe like
something like that you guessed it
subtract and boom just like that we
basically made our popper toy now i
actually went through and i did a few
more things to really kind of make it as
accurate as possible not least of which
was i added a cylinder make this really
small and set that to subtract boom i've
made a little hole but being able to do
these sort of subtractions and additions
and unions and intersects using volumes
it makes so much more sense to me so i
actually went through and just modeled
this entire thing so my idea for how to
animate this thing being squished in was
i was literally just going to deform the
thing into place and then use what's
called a blend shape to animate between
those two different versions of the same
model
and that's what we have here i basically
animate it from the loaded state to the
default state over the course of like
two frames it caused it to fly up into
the air and spin away the first
simulation i did of it i was blown away
it actually popped up and flew up into
the air like the real toy so despite
this being an unsatisfying render you
can't have factories be a hundred
percent faulty
listen every time we do one of these
render challenges there's just
there's a lot of stress in the air you
know and it's like palpable i've found
that when other people around you are
stressed one thing that you can do is
listen to them and really offer
heartfelt words of wisdom courtesy of
today's sponsor squarespace so that's
what we're gonna do and i think it's
really gonna help out everybody around
here let's get started i'm not feeling
good dude i'm so stressed i'm so
overworked if i'm being honest though
the real stress thing has been the fact
g run that sounds really hard but have
you tried using squarespace's beautiful
award-winning templates they've got 24 7
award-winning customer service you don't
need to know anything about building
websites you can just go on there and
get started for yourself today doesn't
it make you feel better to know that
[Music]
that helps
good oh jesus christ hi how are you
feeling throughout all this it's like
third-party stressful you know well i'm
really glad you brought that up because
with squarespace's members areas you can
create a members only area on your
website and you can give members
exclusive content on your website so
matt you can breathe a little bit easier
right my residual stress is down to
pretty much zero i'm all just mildly
stressed ninety percent right but you
could be at a hundred percent i'd like
to go there how do i get to 100
with squarespace's multiple contributors
tools you can open up your website to
other people on your team and then have
those people contribute what they're
good at to your website that really
could uh
bump me up to 100
that's all i can ask my thought is that
if everyone
used squarespace's connected social
media accounts they'd be able to make
one post on their squarespace website
and then it would automatically format
and go out to all their social media
platforms problem solved right that's
what we like when you're in town jake
thanks with squarespace's traffic
overviews tools you can see everybody
that comes into your website what pages
they visit right and then you can make
your site better based on understanding
what people actually like about your
website so your stressor will come down
a little bit
you're an angel
hey guys
uh i just want you guys to know
you can get 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain by going to
squarespace.com
corridor crew
that's amazing
so so hit me with the truth how are you
guys feeling right now
[Applause]
thanks again squarespace for sponsoring
and uh man i just couldn't be happier
with this crew right here you know
[Music]
hey didn't you get fired double fired
dude i came back last week and they
fired me again three's company you're
fired
fired so everyone's got their renders
done and it's time to do the big reveal
but jake is in town this week and he
doesn't know we're doing an unsatisfying
render test so this way we're gonna get
the most authentic reactions from him
and the most proper judging because only
someone who's expecting to be satisfied
can truly be disappointed i expect to be
100
satisfied satisfaction guaranteed
yes
[Music]
please go home oh no
go in the heart come on
[Applause]
god
[Laughter]
you're right there was satisfaction
receptors going off in my brain as he
missed these like little swords with
these little axes i really like the
texturing you did on everything yeah
yeah the just the color palette and the
graphic design is beautiful all the
animation yeah
oh thank you so much yeah i thought it
was pretty great i didn't like how the
ball didn't make it
[Music]
out of 10 satisfying points how
satisfying was that to you you want me
to be honest yeah
well it was still like a seven
honestly because at the beginning
like it wasn't a 10 if it would have
went in it would have been 10. seven uh
you know okay yeah could have been lower
you know dude i started like three or
four different renders and i got
frustrated or it wasn't going well this
is a 24 hour render so
that's all i'll say
time for a little smacking
oh god
oh no that is not straight
oh no
well it wasn't folded
[Music]
[Music]
why
i mean in terms of building a a world
i don't know what program you used for
this but
um
the actual guy who can't get the dollar
bill or the five dollar bill in
obviously that's very frustrating but i
think you could have taken it one step
further you could have showed him in
hunger true hunger pain
he looks like a man a man who's on the
brink who needs the food to survive
peter this isn't satisfying when he puts
it in it comes back out that's not
satisfying did you have the same issue
with the ball in the hole with the bill
in the thing yeah i couldn't the the
bill intake simulator wasn't working so
this is
a
this satisfaction is about a five
nice yeah
okay yeah okay
all right all right
it's not fair okay
great
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wait
[Laughter]
um
satisfaction level here uh
the the the actual like look and texture
of the animation is
dude top notch
um but the fact that the thing doesn't
actually pop until the third round
people got to sit there and watch it
really brings down the satisfaction for
me if i was to say how satisfied i am
i'd say i'd give this a six
i didn't beat jordan let's do that i
beat you though
oh jordan's in my opinion
so far the winner whatever dude i'm
thrilled again seven six five i can't
believe i'm winning my turn
[Music]
yo
[Music]
oh there's another one okay
[Music]
this is different
it might make it this time this might be
the one this is straight up a video game
oh
is there another one one more shot yeah
yeah we got one more shot one more shot
[Music]
that was nice i liked it this is the one
guys
[Music]
and oh we got another shot we got okay
this is the one this is it i believe it
this is the one
he's gonna get the silver back
it's these
who put the statues
oh it is
very very satisfying in a unsatisfying
way right a couple of things but uh the
the color tones like nothing matches
like every color tone is contradictory
to the other ones none of them are
complementary i don't know what's going
on there and then
why doesn't it ever get to the top
the most obvious question why doesn't it
ever get to the top and sit there well i
think they come up with excuses but like
i had to animate this whole thing with
my mouse it was really really hard so i
took the three best shots and rendered
those
yeah oh yeah
i i don't know what was going on with
you and peter when you guys were making
these but they're both pretty bad in
terms of satisfaction levels sam i think
you did a pretty good job i'm pretty
satisfied me too yeah i second that yeah
thanks
if i'm being honest this is
this is like a 4 out of 10.
you give me a 4 out of 10. this is the
most unsatisfying thing i've seen in a
while
that's the worst news i could ever have
sam congratulations man
[Applause]
you silly it's an unsatisfying render
challenge
dude well then
then i mean congratulations to all of
you
i'll take it
i did like a lot of the destruction that
was happening in the beginning sam like
some of the way that these break like
the glade that that glass breaks is
pretty satisfying but i was hoping that
it wouldn't happen to the statue because
it's like why is the statue being put up
then i just want this to be a kind of a
sad reflection
guys horrible job everyone really yeah
those worse
[Applause]
i wasn't satisfied i don't think anybody
else who saw this video is going to be
if you guys think that anyone was
particularly unsatisfying then uh let us
know we're gonna post these on instagram
individually and um then the real loser
will be decided peter yeah
jake
sam don't forget we gotta tell the
audience about the big thing we're doing
next year so 2021 has been a huge year
but 2022 is gonna be an amazing and a
magnificent year all because of a new
partnership that we're forming with